it's a familiar scene in The Border Town
of El Paso Texas people desperately
escaping violence and poverty facing
uncertainty waiting in groups crowding
sidewalks hoping for a chance for a new
home with nothing but the clothes on
their backs and their children at their
side
this mother or two crossed the border
with her one and three-year-old no
family in the U.S only friends and she's
hoping to get to Ohio where she plans to
find any job she can to support her two
girls with little government assistance
Charities are stepping in to provide
Basics like food and blankets at night
the blankets are used for warmth but
during the day they're used to block the
west Texas Sun like this blanket right
here which is from the American Red
Cross many of the migrants have been on
the streets for days but some say it's
better than the life they left behind